Hello listener, this is Jason Bateman along with Will Arnett and Sean Hayes for the podcast called Smartless. If that's a place you're looking for, you've found it, congratulations. It's not a real high concept podcast. One person invites a guest, the other two don't know who that guest is, and then we chat. Here we go. Jason, you missed this last time. Look what I got.
听众朋友们大家好，我是杰森·贝特曼，和威尔·阿奈特以及肖恩·海耶斯一起主持这档名为《Smartless》的播客。如果你是在找这个节目，那恭喜你，找对地方了。这并不是什么高深莫测的播客。我们其中一人邀请一位嘉宾，另外两人事先不知道嘉宾是谁，然后我们就开始聊天。开始了。杰森，上次你错过了这个。看看我拿到了什么。
That's a baby Yoda. It's a baby Yoda. And there's a message on here. Is that from the Mandalorian show? Yeah, Mandalorian. This is from my friend Michael Cohen and the Cohen family, not that Michael Cohen. Look. And he recorded this.
那是尤达宝宝。真的是尤达宝宝。上面还有条留言。那是《曼达洛人》剧里的吗？对，曼达洛人。这是我朋友迈克尔·科恩和科恩一家送的，不是那个迈克尔·科恩。你看。他还录了这个。
Welcome to Smartless, the best podcast in the world with my dear friend Sean Hayes, Jason Bateman and William Arnett. He went William. I like that he went William. Yeah. And baby Yoda said that. So he's the voice of baby Yoda? Yeah.
欢迎来到世界上最棒的播客《Smartless》，我是你们亲爱的朋友肖恩·海耶斯、杰森·贝特曼和威廉·阿奈特。他用了“威廉”。我喜欢他用“威廉”。没错。那是尤达宝宝说的。所以他是尤达宝宝的配音吗？对。
Yeah. Could you not tell? He sounds Latin. I didn't know baby Yoda. Actually he is. Baby Yoda is Latin, huh? I got to watch that show. I'm developing a new show.
是啊。你听不出来吗？他听起来像拉丁裔。我不知道尤达宝宝。其实他就是。尤达宝宝是拉丁裔，是吧？我得去看看那部剧。我正在开发一部新剧。
It's Baby Yoda Nanny. And it's a nanny who works, who looks after her. No, it's just the doll that you leave with your kids and tell them they're watching them. Yeah. It should be noted, Jason's haircut. Have you commented on it? Yeah, it looks good. Finally.
叫《尤达宝宝保姆》。讲的是一个保姆在照顾……不，其实就是个玩偶，你把它留给孩子，告诉他们它在看着他们。对。值得一提的是，杰森的发型。你们评论了吗？对，看起来不错。终于。
It looks good, right? Well, this is guys. Listen. This has just rolled right out of bed. It's such a thick head of hair. I know. It's so thick. But it's a very boyish look he's got going right now, isn't it?
看起来不错，对吧？伙计们，听着。这家伙刚从床上爬起来。头发太厚了。我知道。太厚了。但他现在看起来很有少年感，不是吗？
Yeah. It's very boyish. I know. I'm trying to get respect as an adult, but that's why sometimes I try to grow up my facial hair, but that takes, if you push, it costs me a year, actually, to grow that. Because you're just saying to the world, hey, I'm a man. Yeah. I'm a man.
是啊。非常有少年感。我知道。我正努力以成年人的身份获得尊重，这就是为什么我有时会试着留胡子，但如果硬要留的话，其实得花我一年时间。因为你是在向世界宣告，嘿，我是个男人。对。我是个男人。
Deal with it. All right. So speaking of men, we have a man today. This is a funny man, a family man. And for the next hour, he's a smart-less man. Ladies and gentlemen, Adam Sandler. Adam Sandler. Hey.
接受现实吧。好了，说到男人，我们今天请到了一位男士。他是个风趣的人，顾家的人。在接下来的一个小时里，他就是个“Smartless”男人。女士们先生们，亚当·桑德勒。亚当·桑德勒。嘿。
The one and only. I did the beard. I'm sorry about this. Look it. Now, that's a man. Look at the beard. It's gross. It's gross.
独一无二的。我留了胡子。抱歉啊。你看。那才叫男人。看看这胡子。真恶心。真恶心。
Good to see you all, too. You're moving dime bags or something with a beard like that. Wow. It started off early in the pandemic, and I just kept going because I gained a lot. So it was covering the neck. You gained a lot of weight? Of knowledge. Of knowledge.
见到你们也很高兴。留着那样的胡子，你是在倒卖毒品还是怎么着。哇。这胡子是疫情初期开始留的，我就一直没刮，因为我胖了很多。所以它正好遮住脖子。你胖了很多？是知识的重量。知识的重量。
Yeah. Yeah, a lot of weight. But wait, I just read a report yesterday that said belly fat is now officially medically proven to lessen your life if you have a lot of belly fat. No matter how much other fat you have. Let's see it, Sean. Let's see it, Sean. And scream.
对。对，重量很大。等等，我昨天刚读到一份报告，说医学上已正式证明，如果你腹部脂肪过多，会缩短寿命。不管你身上其他地方有多少脂肪。让我们看看，肖恩。让我们看看，肖恩。然后尖叫。
You guys don't like cookies? Once a week, he brings it out. There it is. The bagel. I don't know who ate the cookies. What'd you call it? The bagel? The bagel.
你们不喜欢饼干吗？他每周都会拿出来。就在那儿。百吉饼。我不知道是谁吃了饼干。你管它叫什么？百吉饼？百吉饼。
Yeah. Squeeze the belly button together. Make a circle. And yeah, Adam. Yeah. Sometimes I say to my husband, I'll switch. I'll fuck her this up. I'll go, fuck that belly.
对。把肚脐挤在一起。围成一个圈。没错，亚当。对。有时我会对我的妻子说，我会换个方式。我会搞砸的。我会说，去他的那个肚子。
Fuck her. That makes sense. That looks good. All right. So, Adam. Yeah. And then, aside from pushing like a bench press or something like that, what's your plan?
去他的。有道理。看起来不错。好了，亚当。对。除了做卧推之类的运动，你有什么计划吗？
Is it going to be diet? Is it going to be exercise? Well, this is what I'm doing, and I just kind of started this. So at the beginning of the pandemic, my buddy was doing the eight hours a day you eat thing, the intermittent fasting. Yeah. Yeah, I don't. So I was doing that during the pandemic, but I was starting eating at like five in the
是靠节食吗？还是靠锻炼？嗯，这是我正在做的，我刚开始。疫情刚开始的时候，我哥们在做那种每天只吃八小时的间歇性禁食。对。对，我没做。疫情期间我一直在做，但我开始吃东西的时间大概是下午五点。
afternoon. I was going deep into the night, and then I'd wake up kind of sick. So then, then I got some bad information. I thought I said to him anytime, and he said, yeah, you picked the hour, so I did it. He responded while chewing, I think. He looks great, but I saw anyways, I started again, I just, I'm trying to calm down and I'm doing one in the afternoon to around seven, seven, 30, I quit. And then you're done chewing until the next morning or afternoon.
我一直吃到深夜，然后醒来时感觉有点不舒服。后来，我得到了一些错误的信息。我以为我问他什么时候吃，他说，对，你自己选时间，所以我就照做了。他当时好像还在嚼着东西。他看起来很棒，但我看到……总之，我又重新开始了，我正试着冷静下来，我从下午一点开始吃，到七点、七点半左右我就停了。然后直到第二天早上或下午之前你都不再进食了。
Yeah, until the next one o'clock rolls around. Oh, buddy, that's so good. That's a good one, but I eat a lot during the six and a half hours. It doesn't work for me. It doesn't work for my body. It doesn't work for me. I tried doing that. I was on a strictly ice cream diet, but yeah.
对，直到第二天一点钟到来。噢，伙计，那太好了。那是个好方法，但我在这六个半小时里吃得太多了。这对我没用。这不适合我的身体。这对我没用。我试过那样做。我之前严格执行冰淇淋饮食法，但是……
You got to try it longer than a couple of days, Will. You know? What do you do, Will? You look good. Well, thank you. Like I said, I've been doing the walk and I've been working out and I've got this real kind of, what I refer to as my jailhouse gym in my garage now. Jason's seen it.
威尔，你得坚持久一点，不能只试几天。你知道吗？你呢，威尔？你看起来不错。噢，谢谢。就像我说的，我一直在走路，一直在锻炼，我现在车库里有个我称之为“监狱健身房”的地方。杰森见过。
It's a disaster, but. But there's weights and like homemade stuff you did. There's weights and then there's like baby carriages and stuff and just crap everywhere. It really looks like a. I have a question, Adam. How long have you been flying a spacecraft? Does that look like that? Looks like a control center.
简直是一场灾难，但是……但里面有哑铃和一些你自己做的东西。有哑铃，还有婴儿车之类的东西，到处都是垃圾。看起来真的像个……我有个问题，亚当。你开宇宙飞船多久了？看起来像那样吗？看起来像个控制中心。
This is in my house, fellas. I just got to Philadelphia. Oh, wow. Wait, what are those? Why do you have? It's some nikes in a plastic box. Those are LeBron James shoes. The man who owns this house knows LeBron.
伙计们，这是在我家里。我刚到费城。噢，哇。等等，那些是什么？你为什么会有？那是塑料盒里的耐克鞋。那是勒布朗·詹姆斯的鞋。住这房子的人认识勒布朗。
I. Do you know the man in the house? I don't. I haven't met him yet. He's pandemic. So you've rent it. He leaves. Oh, you're renting.
我……你认识住这房子的人吗？不认识。我还没见过他。因为疫情。所以你是租的。他搬走了。噢，你是租房住。
I see. I don't know. I just got here two days ago, but he's left those shoes there for people to admire that are renters. I think he was just letting me know that I'm not the only shoe guy. Famous person that he knows. Exactly. Wait a second.
我明白了。我不知道。我两天前才到这儿，但他把那些鞋留在那儿让租客欣赏。我想他只是想让我知道，我不是唯一一个认识名人的鞋迷。没错。等等。
Wait a second. Adam, I have to ask you this because I've never bought it up. I've only met you a handful of times over the years. We don't know each other that well. I have a tremendous amount of respect for you, and I think that you're awesome and hilarious. Same thing. And I. Sounds like something really insulting is about to happen.
等等。亚当，我必须问你这个，因为我从没提过。这些年来我只见过你几次。我们不太熟。我非常尊重你，我觉得你很棒，也很搞笑。我也是。听起来好像要发生什么侮辱人的事了。
No, no, no. One of the funniest things I've ever witnessed. And I've quoted this a thousand times, maybe more, is years ago you were on Letterman. And he said to you, I didn't tell me if you remember this, he said to you, you came on Letterman and you said, you know, Dave, I, he said, how are you doing? You said, you know, I'm, I'm doing okay. But last year I said something and you said to me, what are you an idiot and you really burned me.
不，不，不。这是我见过最搞笑的事情之一。我引用过一千次，甚至更多，就是多年前你上莱特曼的节目。他说，你不用告诉我你记不记得，他说，你上了莱特曼的节目，你说，你知道，戴夫，我……他说，你最近怎么样？你说，你知道，我……我还可以。但去年我说了一些话，你对我说，你是个白痴吗？你真的把我损到了。
And I was thinking about it all year. Just, I wish I'd had a better comeback. So I've been thinking, I finally have a good comeback. And he said, okay. And you said, so ask me again. So Letterman says to you, what are you an idiot? And you said, no, are you? Yeah.
我整整一年都在想这件事。我只是希望当时能有个更好的回击。所以我一直在想，终于想到了一个好的回击。他说，好吧。你说，那你再问我一次。于是莱特曼问你，你是个白痴吗？你说，不，你是吗？对。
Do you remember that? I kind of do. Yeah. Yeah. It was one of my fates. I just, I was such a, it really got me. I'm not kidding. I've repeated it 1500 times.
你记得吗？我有点印象。对。对。那是我最得意的时刻之一。我当时……真的被损到了。我不开玩笑。我重复过一千五百次了。
That's amazing. I used to get so nervous on Letterman. You guys, oh, Letterman. Blackout. Yeah. Blackout nerves. That was the one guy that got you nervous. Yeah.
太棒了。我以前上莱特曼节目时总是很紧张。伙计们，噢，莱特曼。大脑一片空白。对。紧张到断片。那是唯一一个让你紧张的人。对。
I get blackout. Yeah. For sure. Every talk show. Letterman, Letterman just from growing up in high school and thinking he was the best of them all. Yeah. For sure.
我确实会断片。对。肯定的。每个脱口秀都这样。莱特曼，莱特曼是因为我高中时看着他长大，觉得他是所有人里最棒的。对。肯定的。
So witty. I was like, oh, okay, okay, it's coming. And I'd start going, holy shit, like my whole head would spin and I'd feel like I was going to faint the whole time walking out and then you'd see Dave in person and you're like, oh my God, there he is. It was so. Overwhelming. Yeah.
太机智了。我当时想，噢，好吧，好吧，要来了。然后我开始想，天哪，我的头都要转晕了，走出去的时候我一直觉得我要晕倒了，然后你亲眼见到戴夫，你会想，噢天哪，他就在那儿。太让人不知所措了。对。
Yeah. Does that exist for you at all anymore? I mean, you put yourself in the wings right now, about to go on for a talk show, like tomorrow. Yeah. Do you, like you can't shake that. No. It's always going to be a part of you, right?
对。那种感觉现在还存在吗？我是说，如果你现在站在侧台，马上要上一个脱口秀，比如明天。对。你还是摆脱不了那种感觉吗？不。那永远是你的一部分，对吧？
Have you just learned how to manage it? Not that great. My whole career from starting, I did stand up when I was 17 and stuff and I had that same weird thing where I wish I never took the gig right before and I started fattiging and spinning. I forget all my lines and I'd notice everyone else was like laughing and having a good time and I'm like, oh my God, everyone else is ready and then rare occasions I'll go to myself in the daytime.
你只是学会了如何应对它吗？没那么好。我整个职业生涯，从开始做起，我17岁时做单口喜剧，我有那种奇怪的毛病，我总是希望演出前没接那个活，我开始发抖、头晕。我忘了所有的台词，我注意到其他人都在笑，玩得很开心，我心想，噢天哪，其他人准备好了，然后偶尔在白天我会对自己说。
I'll go, don't do that. Don't do that thing where you panic. Let's overcome that now. Get over that. And then don't you question yourself, like why, because I go through the exact same thing and I'm like, why are we, why did I choose this? Yeah. We all wonder, we're always like, why did you choose this?
我会说，别那样做。别再恐慌了。现在克服它。克服它。然后你难道不会质疑自己吗，为什么，因为我也经历过同样的事情，我会想，为什么我们……我为什么要选这个？对。我们都纳闷，我们总是想，你为什么要选这个？
Believe me. It comes up a lot. That's a good one. Yeah. Stick around. Will's got like three of them. No, but it's a good point. Like Adam, I think what's cool is you actually kind of, sometimes you use your nerves.
相信我。这种情况经常出现。那是个好问题。对。留下来吧。威尔有三个这样的问题。不，但这是个好点。亚当，我觉得很酷的是你实际上……有时你利用了你的紧张。
You can see it even in an instance like that. You use it to your advantage and it makes you very accessible because you're not trying to put on, you're not a different character as you are who you are. You're very authentic in that way, which is great. Like, yeah, you're fucking nervous because you're on Letterman. You should be. I'm nervous. Yeah.
即使在那样的时刻你也能看出来。你利用它来发挥优势，这让你显得很平易近人，因为你没有在装模作样，你不是在扮演一个不同的角色，你就是你自己。在这方面你非常真实，这很棒。就像，对，你他妈的紧张，因为你在莱特曼的节目上。你应该紧张。我很紧张。对。
But you weren't nervous for this bullshit today. I was nervous. Sure I was. I mean, I liked it though. I listened to the episodes. They're all great. Come on. It's excellent.
但你今天来这儿胡扯可没紧张。我很紧张。当然了。我是说，但我喜欢这样。我听过这些节目。都很棒。得了吧。太出色了。
And now I was psyched to be here. And I don't know. I'm the same way as you guys. I'm the same way of every move you make. You go, didn't I already prove myself? Dude, why the hell am I trying to prove myself? What the fuck am I here? Here we go again.
而且我来这儿很兴奋。我不知道。我和你们一样。我做的每一个举动都一样。你会想，我不是已经证明过自己了吗？伙计，我到底为什么要证明自己？我他妈为什么在这儿？又来了。
Yeah, exactly. The only thing that can happen is it can go bad. You know, but that quality that Will's talking about that you have that's so personable and it's so kind and so authentic and so honest and so human. Has it always been like that or do you think that it's gotten even better now that you are incredibly successful and some of the ease has come into your life because you've basically won? Have you gotten even nicer or like some people I'm sure you've worked with as I have, people
对，没错。唯一可能发生的就是搞砸了。你知道，但威尔提到的那种你拥有的品质，那种平易近人、善良、真实、诚实和人性化的品质。一直都是这样吗？还是你觉得现在你取得了巨大的成功，生活变得轻松了一些，因为你基本上已经赢了，所以这种品质变得更好了？你变得更友善了吗？或者像我合作过的一些人一样，有些人……
actually get mean and entitled when they get successful. You seem to have gone the other way. Yeah. You guys all seem the same also. It's like I had a, I think when I was young, I didn't know what I was doing as a comedian. I didn't know what I was doing as an actor. I was a little all over the place. I think I was a little more aggressive back then because I guess I wanted this so bad.
在成功之后反而变得刻薄和自以为是。你似乎走向了反面。对。你们看起来也都一样。我想我年轻的时候，作为喜剧演员我不知道自己在做什么。作为演员我也不知道自己在做什么。我有点不知所措。我想那时候我更有攻击性，因为我想得到这个机会太迫切了。
You know, I wanted to work or I wanted whatever the hell I wanted and I probably was mad at myself for not being great. I was a little more aggressive in my early twenties and then I started going by the time I was like 28, 30, I started calming down and being able to just relax a little more, but it took a while. You guys know Colin Quinn, right? Yeah. I'm a comedian.
你知道，我想工作，或者不管我想要什么，我可能因为自己不够出色而对自己生气。我二十出头的时候更有攻击性，然后到了28、30岁左右，我开始冷静下来，能够稍微放松一点，但这花了一些时间。你们认识科林·奎因，对吧？对。我是个喜剧演员。
Hilarious. I think he's one of the greatest comedians and when I went to NYU, used to emcee the shows and he would talk to me after my shows. I think the reason they used to hire me is I used to bring a crowd. Even though I wasn't that good, there was this place called the Paper Moon and I used to bring a crowd. They used to, from NYU. Colin used to say, it's so much funnier hanging out when we're talking in the daytime.
太搞笑了。我觉得他是最伟大的喜剧演员之一，我上纽约大学时，他经常主持演出，演出后他会跟我聊天。我想他们雇我的原因是我能带来观众。尽管我当时没那么好，有个叫“纸月亮”的地方，我总能带去观众。他们以前……来自纽约大学。科林以前常说，白天聊天的时候你有趣多了。
You're doing something weird up to you, you're not really being yourself and I used to try to go, okay, I got to be more myself and then I would just panic right away and start doing something else. I just didn't, I guess I wasn't comfortable with being myself and then took a while to get to sitting it and just be okay with not getting a laugh and plowing through and that kind of stuff. Did you go to NYU for drama or for acting? Yeah, yeah, I went to Strasburg.
你一上台就变得很奇怪，你并没有真正做自己，我以前试着想，好吧，我得更像我自己，然后我就会立刻恐慌，开始做别的事情。我只是……我想我不习惯做自己，后来花了一些时间才适应，才接受即使没得到笑声也没关系，继续演下去之类的。你是去纽约大学学戏剧还是表演？对，对，我去了斯特拉斯堡。
Same. Yeah. Okay, so I have a godson who's also going to New York right now to Tish and he not only has to go through drama classes and comedy and all that stuff, but he has to go through musical theater classes and so when I saw you do opera man for the first time, which is one of the funniest characters I've ever seen, I was like, holy shit, Adam Sandler can really sing and then you would bring out the guitar and sing like he's always hilarious. So please tell me you did musical theater in college because in my mind that would be
我也是。对。好吧，我有个教子现在也在纽约上提斯艺术学院，他不仅要上戏剧课、喜剧课之类的，还得上音乐剧课，所以当我第一次看到你演“歌剧男”时，那是我见过最搞笑的角色之一，我当时想，天哪，亚当·桑德勒真的会唱歌，然后你会拿出吉他唱歌，他总是那么搞笑。所以请告诉我你在大学里演过音乐剧，因为在我看来那会是……
one of the funniest things in the world. Man, I auditioned for everything at NYU. I didn't get anything. You didn't? Oh, I want to see you do Technicolor Dreamcoat or something. I did as a kid though. I was in Oliver. I was in Oliver.
世界上最搞笑的事情之一。伙计，我在纽约大学试镜过所有东西。我什么都没得到。你没有？噢，我想看你演《约瑟夫与神奇彩衣》之类的。我小时候演过。我演过《雾都孤儿》。我演过《雾都孤儿》。
I did, I played, they named a guy. I didn't really, there wasn't really, I had two lines and they said, you're, I think Charlie Bates. They said, you're Charlie Bates and I was like, yeah, I'm Charlie Bates. I kind of wanted to be the Dodger, right? And they were like, well, you're not him. You're Charlie Bates. I was like, yeah, yeah.
我演了，他们给了一个人名。我真的……其实没什么，我有两句台词，他们说，你是，我想是查理·贝茨。他们说，你是查理·贝茨，我说，对，我是查理·贝茨。我其实想演道奇，对吧？他们说，嗯，你不是他。你是查理·贝茨。我说，对，对。
Oh, could you be a great Dodger? I thought so too. You got a pick and pocket or two, right? Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. How about Smitty on the Cosby show? Was that your first, that's not your first role. My first thing I ever did was show time at the Apollo. I did stand up.
噢，你能成为一个伟大的道奇吗？我也这么想。你得偷个钱包什么的，对吧？对，对，对，对。那《考斯比一家》里的斯密蒂呢？那是你的第一个角色吗？那不是你的第一个角色。我做过的第一件事是《阿波罗剧院秀》。我做了单口喜剧。
I did five minutes, yeah, and I was, wasn't that great, but I got, I tell me like the first, first joke you ever told her. And if you'd like, I could tell you mine. Okay. Well, the one that worked for me back then was, it was something I heard my father say to my mother, but I, and I used it. I pretended it happened to me. I said, I was driving up here in a cab and the driver killed a dog on the way.
我做了五分钟，对，我当时……没那么好，但我……告诉我你讲的第一个笑话。如果你愿意，我可以告诉你我的。好吧。当时对我管用的那个是，那是我听我父亲对我母亲说的话，但我用了它。我假装那是发生在我身上的。我说，我坐出租车来这儿，司机在路上撞死了一只狗。
I said, he didn't hit the dog with a car. He got out and stabbed. That was my big, that was my guaranteed laugh. And that happened because my mother, my mother was, they were in the car and my mother goes, the man, my father said, this guy killed the dog driving the other day. My mother goes, what happened? He hit it and he goes, no, he stabbed it you. And so I went, Oh God, that's a pretty good one.
我说，他不是用车撞的狗。他下车把它捅死了。那是我的杀手锏，保证能让人笑。那是因为我母亲，我母亲当时……他们在车里，我母亲说，那个人，我父亲说，这家伙前几天开车撞死了狗。我母亲说，怎么回事？他撞死它了吗？他说，不，他把它捅死了。所以我当时想，噢天哪，那真不错。
What's yours, Sean? Oh, I was terrible. I was nowhere near as talented or funny as you are. I was horrible. These guys know the one that I won't repeat, but the other one was, and it's long. So you can't, it's like, it's like 20 seconds long. Okay. So it's just long for a joke.
你的呢，肖恩？噢，我太烂了。我远没有你那么有天赋或搞笑。我太糟糕了。这些家伙知道那个我不会重复的笑话，但另一个是，而且很长。所以你不能……它大概有20秒长。好吧。所以对于一个笑话来说太长了。
So I would go, you know, they say on Mars, the atmosphere is like 95% carbon dioxide and 5% oxygen. So I imagine one day when we live there, we'll breathe something like this. And they didn't laugh at that. They nobody laughed. I believe I'm crying. I left crying. That's solid.
所以我以前会说，你知道，他们说在火星上，大气层里95%是二氧化碳，5%是氧气。所以我设想有一天当我们住在那里时，我们会呼吸这样的空气。他们没笑。没人笑。我相信我当时都快哭了。我哭着离开了。那很扎实。
So hold your finger up when you did it. I like that too. That's a good one. Adam, what about this discovered by comedian Dennis Miller thing? Did that happen at the Apollo? I can't imagine. You know what it was. So I did stand up when I went to NYU and then Dennis didn't really discover me.
所以你讲的时候竖起手指。我也喜欢那个。那是个好笑话。亚当，关于那个被喜剧演员丹尼斯·米勒发现的事呢？那是发生在阿波罗剧院吗？我无法想象。你知道是怎么回事。我在纽约大学时做了单口喜剧，然后丹尼斯并没有真正发现我。
He just told Lauren Michaels about me. He said, there's a young kid who's funny. But when I was young, I went to school with Anthony Quinn's son Lorenzo. He was in my acting class and he told Bill Cosby about me and I got an introduction to the casting agent over there whose name was Barry Moss. Do you guys remember Barry Moss? I feel like I do. He used to cast a lot of stuff back in the day.
他只是告诉了洛恩·迈克尔斯关于我的事。他说，有个年轻人很有趣。但我年轻时，我和安东尼·奎因的儿子洛伦佐是同学。他在我的表演课上，他向比尔·考斯比提到了我，我被介绍给了那边的选角导演，他叫巴里·莫斯。你们记得巴里·莫斯吗？我觉得我记得。他以前选过很多戏。
So he got me an audition and I played Smitty on four episodes while I was going to NYU. That was my first job. And that was big. That was huge. I mean, Cosby show was enormous. It was the biggest show on the planet. It was incredible. And that's where I developed the whole spinning thing right before going on.
所以他让我去试镜，我在上纽约大学时在四集里演了斯密蒂。那是我的第一份工作。那很重要。那太大了。我是说，考斯比秀太火了。那是地球上最大的节目。太不可思议了。那就是我养成上台前那种“旋转”习惯的地方。
I was spinning like, oh my God, I got six lines. I've got a choke so badly. And I don't know. I became friends with Malcolm though. He used to call me daddy. He'd be like, you got this man. Yeah. He's such a good guy.
我当时旋转着想，噢天哪，我有六句台词。我得演得太烂了。我不知道。但我成了马尔科姆的朋友。他以前叫我爸爸。他会说，你能行的，伙计。对。他真是个好人。
Yeah. Yeah. Wow. So then how long after that did SNL happen? How old were you when that happened? Well, it happened when I was 23. I moved out to, I graduated at NYU and then I moved to LA and I was living out in Van Eyes.
对。对。哇。那之后多久《周六夜现场》才找你？那时候你多大？嗯，发生的时候我23岁。我搬到……我从纽约大学毕业，然后搬到洛杉矶，住在范奈斯。
Beautiful. Gorgeous. Yeah. Yes. Right on the water. Beautiful. And I lived with four guys from NYU also and then somehow I got Saturday night live and moved back.
太美了。华丽。对。是的。就在水边。太美了。我和另外四个纽约大学的家伙住在一起，然后不知怎么的我就进了《周六夜现场》，又搬了回来。
Well, did you go and audition in LA? Did Lauren come up? Yeah. Chicago. When I auditioned, it was me and Chris Rock and Dana Gould and a couple other guys. At Second City or? At the Chicago Improv. Oh, at Chicago Improv.
嗯，你是去洛杉矶试镜的吗？洛恩来了吗？对。芝加哥。我试镜的时候，有我和克里斯·洛克、达纳·古尔德还有其他几个家伙。在第二城市剧团还是？在芝加哥即兴剧场。噢，在芝加哥即兴剧场。
Okay. Yeah. And then I remember Lauren was there and Robert Smigel was there and Marcy Klein and a couple others and Chris Rock got it immediately after the show and me and Rock know each other since we're like 17 also. And so I saw Lauren run over to Rock and I was like, oh man, okay, he's got it. I'm out. And then I was flying home and no one talked to me and I was flying home and remember on
好吧。对。我记得洛恩在那儿，罗伯特·斯密格尔也在，还有玛西·克莱恩和其他几个人，克里斯·洛克在演出后立刻就被录用了，我和洛克从17岁起就认识了。所以我看到洛恩跑向洛克，我心想，噢伙计，好吧，他被录用了。我没戏了。然后我坐飞机回家，没人跟我说话，我坐飞机回家，记得在飞机上吗。
the planes, you used to put a credit card in and it was like 25 bucks a minute and stuff. Yeah. Right. So I was scared to use that because I knew my father would kill me for wasting money, but I was just flying and flying and I was like, I got to call my agent, man. So I put the credit card in and he called and I said, did they say anything? They liked you. They thought you, some of your writing was good.
以前你要插一张信用卡，一分钟要25美元之类的。对。没错。所以我不敢用，因为我知道我父亲会因为我浪费钱而杀了我，但我当时一直在飞，我心想，我得给我的经纪人打电话，伙计。所以我插了信用卡，他打了过来，我说，他们说什么了吗？他们喜欢你。他们觉得你写的一些东西很好。
I said, oh, okay. And what's that mean? They were like, well, they want, maybe want you as a writer. And I said, what do you mean? I think I was like insane and I was like, I want to be a, but I want to be a star. And they were like, I love the guy next to you on the plane probably was just like, oh boy. Yeah.
我说，噢，好吧。那是什么意思？他们说，嗯，他们想，也许想让你当编剧。我说，什么意思？我想我当时疯了，我说，我想成为一个……但我想要成为明星。他们说，我爱你。旁边飞机上的那个人可能只是想，噢天哪。对。
This guy wants to be a star. Quietly on a plane. But I want to be a star. Get in line, buddy. Get in line. We all knew. Yeah, man. I don't know.
这家伙想成为明星。在飞机上小声说。但我想要成为明星。排队吧，伙计。排队吧。我们都知道。对，伙计。我不知道。
So eventually I got hired as a writer, a writer for what, like a year and then, and then on camera. Yeah. I did. It was a thing called writer feature player and, and, and me and Spade and Schneider had that. And, and you would do that. I'm sure you guys all know this stuff, but you would write, write for everyone else and
所以最终我被雇为编剧，编剧做了大概一年，然后……然后上镜。对。我做了。那叫“编剧兼特约演员”，我和斯佩德、施耐德都有过。你会做那个。我相信你们都知道这些，但你会为其他人写剧本，然后。
then give yourself a line, like as the delivery guy and try to get on and score and, you know, and you'd score after 10 shows, they started going, all right, that guy's okay. I'll let's, let's give him a couple of hearts. Right. Gotcha. Used to see that a lot with JB smooth. He would, he would all get himself into sketches. Oh yeah.
给自己加一句台词，比如送货员之类的，试着上镜表现一下，你知道，演了10集之后，他们开始觉得，好吧，那家伙还行。让我们给他几个镜头。对。明白了。以前经常看到JB·斯穆夫那样。他总是把自己加进小品里。噢对。
Always see JB on there and you'd be like, oh yeah, but how cool you go for your, your audition and it's there with Lauren and Marcy, of course, and Smigel and you couldn't have known, of course, that that would become this like lifelong partnership. Yeah. I mean, how incredible, how wild, right? When you looked at that moment. Yeah. Yeah.
总是看到JB在上面，你会想，噢对，但你试镜的时候能和洛恩、玛西、斯密格尔在一起多酷啊，你当然不可能知道那会成为这种终身的合作伙伴关系。对。我是说，多不可思议，多疯狂，对吧？当你回顾那一刻时。对。对。
Sure, man. I mean, Smigel was, in fact, I heard later that Smigel was kind of in my court that he was going, that, that one kid was funny. He, I think we need that on the show. Somebody young and they were like, well, we already have David and Rob. We don't need any more of that. And so Smigel and Jim Downey, I heard would, would stand up for me a little bit and Lauren liked me.
当然，伙计。我是说，斯密格尔，事实上我后来听说斯密格尔当时站在我这边，他说，那个孩子很有趣。他，我想我们需要那样的人在节目里。某个年轻人，他们说，嗯，我们已经有大卫和罗伯了。我们不需要更多那样的人了。所以斯密格尔和吉姆·唐尼，我听说会为我争取一下，洛恩也喜欢我。
He thought I was good. He just didn't know what to do with me. I was, I, I wasn't easy to digest. I was mumbling up there and I was a nervous wreck and I was like, I used to be when somebody heckled me. I used to like yell at them and not say anything funny. No one is funny. You're getting pissed off.
他觉得我不错。他只是不知道该拿我怎么办。我当时……我很难被消化。我在上面嘟囔，我紧张得要命，我以前……当有人起哄时。我以前会冲他们大喊大叫，却说不出什么有趣的话。没人觉得有趣。你只是气急败坏。
Oh, well, I, I, I turned it into something good. But in the beginning, I used to just be psychotic and get like challenged people to something like him curse at him. And see the way he just dropped his face right then it just got like deadly fucking serious. I love like there, there's just, there's no middle with you. Like he's either super sweet and like, oh, I can't get out of my way. And then just drop the gloves and I'm going to fucking kill you. Yeah.
噢，好吧，我把它变成了一些好的东西。但刚开始时，我只是精神错乱，会挑战别人，或者冲他们咒骂。看他刚才脸垮下来的样子，真的变得极其严肃。我喜欢……你身上没有中间地带。要么超级甜，噢，我无法摆脱困境。然后立刻扔掉手套，我要他妈的杀了你。对。
I love those swings. I don't even know how that happened. I just, because I'm, I don't want to fight anybody. I'd get, I'd probably get killed, but I was always ready to go. Have you been in a lot of fights as a kid or when I was a kid, when I was a kid, now I would literally just run so fast. Anytime I feel it coming, I start, my heart's pounded through my chest and I'm like, oh shit, I got to get out of here.
我喜欢这种反差。我甚至不知道那是怎么发生的。我只是……因为我不想和任何人打架。我可能会被打死，但我总是准备好要干架。你小时候打过很多架吗？小时候，小时候，现在我真的会跑得飞快。每当我感觉到要打架时，我的心就会狂跳，心想，噢该死，我得离开这儿。
But back then I back as a kid, yeah, I'm sure you guys did the same. It doesn't hurt as much to get hit when you're little. I like the idea that Lauren's going like, hmm, I guess we could use a nervous mumbler. Now what about, is it true that they fired you and Farley in 95 or is that overstated? No, no, I mean, what happened was, it was kind of the end of it. People, we were repeating ourselves, I'm sure. There was a new guy running NBC. He didn't, he didn't like the young guys that much.
但那时候，小时候，对，我相信你们也一样。小时候被打没那么疼。我喜欢洛恩当时想，嗯，我想我们可以用一个紧张的嘟囔者。那关于……他们95年解雇你和法利是真的吗？还是夸大了？不，不，我是说，发生的事情是，那算是结束了。人们，我们肯定在重复自己。NBC换了个新老板。他不怎么喜欢年轻人。
He didn't like us. I think he didn't like Norm McDonald and he kept saying, we got to get rid of them. Nobody likes them. And Lauren was standing up for us saying, trying to defend us and kept us on a while. And then I got a call from my manager, you know, everyone at Brillstein grade kind of represented every guy on the show and woman on the show. So I got, hey, maybe it's time to move on to me kind of call and I was like, I don't know, man.
他不喜欢我们。我想他不喜欢诺姆·麦克唐纳，他一直说，我们得除掉他们。没人喜欢他们。洛恩当时站在我们这边，试图保护我们，让我们多留了一会儿。然后我接到了经纪人的电话，你知道，布里尔斯坦·格雷公司的每个人都代理了节目里的每个人。所以我接到电话，嘿，也许是时候继续前进了，我当时想，我不知道，伙计。
I think maybe I'll do another year or something. They were like, yeah, but maybe you should move on. I was like, nah, I want to stay. I think I'll stay and they kept going, I think it's time to move on. I was like, do I have to move on? They were like, it's good if you move on. I was like, okay, okay, now I got you. All right, I'm moving on then.
我想也许我再做一年之类的。他们说，对，但也许你应该继续前进。我说，不，我想留下来。我想我会留下来，他们一直说，我想是时候继续前进了。我说，我非得继续前进吗？他们说，如果你继续前进会更好。我说，好吧，好吧，我明白了。好吧，那我就继续前进。
So it was kind of like a fake quit, fake try to get a beat them right to firing me. That was like me at every high school I went to swear to God, really? You got kicked out. I'm like, no, I didn't get kicked out. They just asked me not to return. What did you do to get in trouble growing up? I did all this stupid stuff. I was smoking cigarettes in the, I grew up in Canada, so there were a lot of woods to
所以那就像是一种假辞职，假装试图在他们解雇我之前先走。那就像我在我上过的每一所高中一样，发誓，真的？你被开除了。我说，不，我没被开除。他们只是要求我不要回来。你小时候惹什么麻烦了？我做了所有那些蠢事。我在……我是在加拿大长大的，所以有很多树林可以逃进去。
escape to. So I was always out there drinking airplane bottles and smoking bots. I was just, but also I was a wise ass. I was like, I said to my dad actually once, I was such a wise ass. And of course, the worst, the infraction or the bigger, the joke that you can make and especially at the teacher's expense, the bigger, the laugh you'd get from the audience or as I'd call my classmates. And so I would fuck around and they get really mad.
所以我总是在外面喝小瓶装的酒，抽烟。我只是……而且我还是个自以为是的家伙。我其实有一次对我爸说，我真是个自以为是的家伙。当然，最糟糕的，违规行为或者你能开的最大的玩笑，尤其是在老师身上，你从观众那里得到的笑声就越大，或者我称之为我的同学。所以我以前会胡闹，他们会非常生气。
And years later, I remember my dad was out here and I just built this house and it was like everything. And my dad was like, wow, this house is beautiful. And I said, yeah, who knew that fucking around could pay off, huh? And he finally had to admit like, yeah, you're kind of right. Cause I was a pain in the ass. You know what I mean? Like my poor dad.
多年后，我记得我爸来这儿，我刚盖好这房子，就像一切都……我爸说，哇，这房子真漂亮。我说，是啊，谁知道胡闹也能有回报，对吧？他终于不得不承认，是啊，你说得有点对。因为我以前真是个讨厌鬼。你知道我的意思吗？我可怜的爸爸。
Sure. Sure. Man. You figure out how to channel it. Yeah. All right. So then were things sort of set up in a way where transitioning out of that show and into other possible sources of employment were kind of set up?
当然。当然。伙计。你找到了如何引导它的方法。对。好了，那么当时的情况是否已经安排好，让你从那个节目过渡到其他可能的就业来源？
Like were you feeling confident? Yeah. Did you go right into, was it happy Gilmore was first out of there? I think I did Billy Madison when I was on the show. By the way, when I got fired. I was confident until I got fired. And then I was like, oh no. Yeah.
比如你当时感觉自信吗？对。你是直接进入……是《快乐吉尔莫》第一个出来的吗？我想我在节目里的时候拍了《阿呆与阿瓜》。顺便说一句，我被解雇的时候。我一直很自信，直到我被解雇。然后我心想，噢不。对。
That's the way that works. Right. I kept while I was there going, these guys don't get it what I got man. They don't understand. And then right when they were like, yeah, go do it on your own then I was like, holy shit. First of all, you humiliated that people don't want you and you got to tell people like, yeah, I'm not on the show and they're looking you in the eyes going, you got fired. And you're like, no, you know, you're making up shit.
事情就是这样运作的，对吧？我在那儿的时候一直想，这些家伙不明白我有什么，伙计。他们不理解。然后当他们说，好吧，那你就自己去干吧，我当时想，天哪。首先，你被羞辱了，人们不想要你，你还得告诉别人，对，我不在那个节目了，他们看着你的眼睛说，你被解雇了。你却说，不，你知道，你在编造谎言。
But it's like doing what we do, you're effectively getting fired at the end of every single job. You have to go find another job. And if you're having a really good year as an actor, you get fired like six or seven times. You know, like you've got six or seven and you have like, there's no guarantee. There's no diploma that you can kind of job interview after job interview. And it's, it's, I remember buying the attitude that I realized I should have been renting when, you know, things kind of dried up and I was really confident until they just didn't
但这就像我们做的工作，你在每一份工作结束时实际上都被解雇了。你必须去寻找下一份工作。如果你作为演员过得很好，你会被解雇六七次。你知道，你有六七次，没有保证。没有文凭，你只能一次又一次地面试。我记得我买了一种态度，我意识到当事情枯竭时我应该租用它，我当时真的很自信，直到他们不再需要我了。
want me anymore. And it's like, well, now you got to build up a whole ego and, and, and coping mechanism to get yourself confident that's not reliant on employment. That's really hard to do. Oh God. Yeah. Sit in the bench and being shook up. I'll tell you, no, no kidding. I loved you when I was a kid. I thought you were incredible. I swear to God, I thought you were cool as shit.
现在你必须建立起整个自我和应对机制，让自己变得自信，而不依赖于就业。这真的很难做到。噢天哪。对。坐在板凳上，被震住了。我告诉你，不开玩笑。我小时候很喜欢你。我觉得你不可思议。我发誓，我觉得你酷毙了。
You guys too. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I wanted to look like you. Be like cool and calm and funny like that. And I, and I always thought you were awesome. I'm not lying to you.
你们也是。对。对。对。我想看起来像你们一样。变得像那样酷、冷静、有趣。而且我一直觉得你很棒。我没骗你。
And I loved your sister too. Thank you. Do you remember Jason's show? He had that show. It's your move. Did you ever see that? It was like a spin off of Silver Spoons. I think so.
我也很喜欢你姐姐。谢谢。你记得杰森的节目吗？他有那个节目。《轮到你了》。你看过吗？那像是《银匙》的衍生剧。我想是吧。
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I think so. But I think I knew more is valid on the Hogan family was after that or Valerie. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
对。对。对。我想是吧。但我认为我知道更多的是《霍根一家》之后的《瓦莱丽》。对。对。对。
When Jason, when Jason got his star on the, on the walk of fame out here in Hollywood, he was a big Hollywood guy and so when he was in Hollywood, we're worried because he's a liberal elite and so anyway. So I get up and they asked me, he asked me to say a couple of words and I said, you know, when I was growing up, I remember watching family ties and seeing Justine Bateman and thinking, man, I wonder if she's got a brother. That's so good of a man. But I loved them.
当杰森在好莱坞星光大道上获得星星时，他是个大人物，所以当他在好莱坞时，我们很担心，因为他是自由派精英，所以无论如何。我站起来，他们让我说几句，我说，你知道，我小时候，记得看《成长的烦恼》，看到贾斯汀·贝特曼，心想，天哪，不知道她有没有哥哥。那太好了，伙计。但我爱他们。
We felt the same way. This comes up all the time. We used to always look at Jason and be like, oh man, that guy's, he was a smart ass. He was confident. He had great hair. Oh man. Oh, I was so confident. I thought I was such hot shit and then the phone stopped ringing.
我们也有同样的感觉。这种情况经常出现。我们以前总是看着杰森，心想，噢天哪，那家伙，他是个聪明人。他很自信。他头发很好。噢天哪。噢，我当时太自信了。我以为自己很了不起，然后电话就不响了。
I did not know what to do. Well, yeah. My twenties was a whole regroup. I just had to build it back up from zero. Jason and I had lunch like decade to go at the Chateau Marmont, which houses the liberal elite. That's right. And Jason said to me, I don't know if you remember this, Jason, you said to me, we were
我不知道该怎么办。嗯，对。我的二十多岁是整个重组期。我不得不从零开始重建。杰森和我十年前在马尔蒙庄园吃过午饭，那里住着自由派精英。没错。杰森对我说，我不知道你记不记得，杰森，你对我说，我们当时只是在谈论职业生涯，无论起起落落，你说，这一切都不由你决定。这一切都不由你决定。对。对。试图控制那些你无法控制的事情。这不是精英管理，你知道，就像在体育运动中，如果你是个300打击率的击球手，你就能保证就业，但在表演或任何形式的艺术中，请原谅这个词。
just talking about careers and whatever and the ups and downs and you said, none of it is up to you. None of this is up to you. Yeah. Yeah. To try and control things that are out of your control. It's not a meritocracy, you know, like in sports, like if you're a 300 hitter, you're guaranteed employment in acting or any form of pardon the term art.
这太主观了。你不能依赖于，嗯，我是唱歌最好的，或者画画最好的，或者他们……这不重要，在谁眼里最好，你知道。所以亚当，那么，考虑到这一点，我觉得你所做的事情中有一点真的很棒，你取得了巨大的成功。但是，你知道，我试过，尤其是在过去几年里，我不希望我的工作定义我作为一个人的身份，或者我有多快乐。这关乎家庭。
It's so subjective. You can't, you can't rely on, well, I'm the best at singing or the best at painting or they, it doesn't matter the best in whose eye, you know. And then so Adam, so kind of taking that, like one of the things that I think is really awesome about what you've, you've done, you've had incredible success. But is, is, you know, I, I've tried to, especially in the last couple of years, I don't want my work to define who I am as a person or how happy I am. It's about family.
我知道你是个非常顾家的人，有很多非常亲密的朋友，甚至在你的工作中，你做你想做的事情，你做这些是因为你知道这需要时间，然后你知道这会占用学校的时间之类的。感觉你把一切都调整得适合你的生活，确保你快乐，你的幸福。你真的不是那种好莱坞人。我可以这么说。
I know you're a really big family guy that a lot of really close friends and even in your work, you do stuff that you want to do and you do stuff because you know it's going to take time and then you know that it's, you know, it cuts into school and all that kind of stuff. And it feels like you gear everything towards making it fit your life and making sure that you're happy and your happiness. You're truly not a Hollywood guy. I can say that.
而且你不会用它来定义自己，对吧？我有点，你知道，我运气好，得到了合适的职业，有机会去做。并不是每个人都有这种奢侈。我相信如果他们能，你知道，只是对公司老板说，嘿，让我在十月做吧，因为，你知道，我运气很好。但你赢得了那个位置。
And, and you don't define yourself by it, right? I kind of, you know, I lucked into having the, the career of getting the right stuff and get to do it. And not everybody has that luxury. I'm sure more people would do what I'm doing if they could just, you know, just say to the head of a company, Hey, let me do it in October because it's, you know, I got a lot of luck on my side. But you earned that position.
你真的赢得了。过了一段时间我才明白，过了一段时间。对。让我，让我很快问你一件事。回到威尔刚才说的，因为当你年轻时，你第一次进入电影界，有多少成功是像，你知道，经纪人业务驱动的，你只是顺便搭个顺风车，有多少是自我生成的，有点雄心勃勃地直接来自你。
You really have. I got that after a while, after a while. Yeah. Let me, let me really quick ask you something about that. And then back to what Will was saying, because when you were younger and you broke into film for the first time and how much of that success was like, you know, agent business driven and you were just along for the ride and how much of it was self generated and kind of ambitiously coming directly from you.
我以一种奇怪的方式很有野心。我只是，我总是……刚开始时，嘿，对，对，对，也许，也许下次，当我试镜时他们会雇别人。我记得小时候21、22岁时试镜了几部电影，他们总是选别人，我当时想，该死，这些家伙不明白，伙计。我当时真是个混蛋，你知道，无论他们选谁，我都会想，噢对，好吧，伙计。就像我很火一样。
I was ambitious in a weird way. I just, I always kind of got in the beginning, Hey, yeah, yeah, yeah, maybe, maybe next time they would hire somebody else when I would do auditions and stuff. I remember auditioning for a few movies as a kid when I was like 21, 22, and they had always picked somebody else and I was like, God damn, these guys don't get it, man. I was such an asshole, you know, and whoever they picked, I would be like, Oh yeah, okay, man. Like I was hot.
我当时有一种奇怪的野心。我只是，我一开始总是觉得，嘿，是啊，是啊，也许，也许下次他们会雇别人，当我参加试镜之类的活动时。我记得小时候，大概21、22岁的时候，我试镜过几部电影，他们总是选了别人，我就想，该死，这些人根本不懂，伙计。我当时真是个混蛋，你知道，无论他们选了谁，我都会想，哦，好吧，伙计。就好像我很抢手一样。
Mistake. Yeah, what a mistake. And then I, I wrote Billy Madison with Tim Hurley and when we were on Saturday Night Live and I gave it to, to Lauren and Lauren was already doing Tommy boy with Chris. And so funny movie. Oh yeah, that's awesome and he's, he was, it was the first time me and Chris had either or kind of thing. And Lauren said, we're doing Tommy boy.
失误。没错，真是个失误。后来我和蒂姆·赫利一起写了《阿呆闯学府》，当时我们还在《周六夜现场》，我把它交给了洛恩，而洛恩当时已经在和克里斯拍《小大卫》了。那部电影很有趣。哦，没错，那太棒了，那是我和克里斯第一次有那种二选一的情况。洛恩说，我们在拍《小大卫》。
We can't do Billy Madison. Actually Tommy boy used to be called Billy the third. It was really movies. Yeah. They would like to the two Billy movies and we would look at each other like, who's the guy to pick and they, and they picked, you know, Tommy boy and, and I was going, Oh man, Oh man, I guess that's done. We'll write another one, Hurley.
我们不能拍《阿呆闯学府》。其实《小大卫》以前叫《比利三世》。那真是两部电影。没错。他们就像是在面对两部比利电影，我们面面相觑，心想谁才是被选中的那个人，结果他们选了《小大卫》，我当时心想，天哪，天哪，看来这事黄了。赫利，我们再写一部吧。
And then like, I was in this movie called Airheads and the producer of that one called me like five months later, he's like, I read this script you and Hurley hero called Billy Madison. Do you want to do that? And I said, yeah, yeah, yeah, why, what do you mean? And he was like, I could get that done for you for like $6 million budget. I was like, I was like, I get $6 million. He goes, no, not not you, I don't know what any of that shit meant.
后来，我拍了一部叫《空头支票》的电影，那部电影的制片人五个月后给我打电话，他说，我读了你和赫利写的那个叫《阿呆闯学府》的剧本。你想拍那部戏吗？我说，想啊，想啊，为什么，你什么意思？他说，我可以帮你以600万美元的预算把它拍出来。我说，我说，我能拿到600万美元？他说，不，不是给你，我根本不知道那是什么意思。
But he got it fucking, he did problem child at Universal, which was a low budget movie and made a lot of money. So they said, get some more of those kinds of things. So somehow Bob Simon's got this movie. I asked Lauren, I said, no, that movie you said you didn't want to do is that okay, if I do it with this other guy, he's like, do anything you want. So I did Billy Madison and then that kind of got me going. I mean, I remember when I first did that, everything that they talked to me about doing
但他确实把它搞定了，他在环球影业拍了《宝贝小天才》，那是一部低成本电影，但赚了很多钱。所以他们说，再多找点那种类型的片子。所以不知怎么的，鲍勃·西蒙斯拿到了这部电影。我问洛恩，我说，嘿，你说不想拍的那部电影，如果我和别人一起拍，没问题吧？他说，你想拍什么都行。所以我拍了《阿呆闯学府》，那部戏让我走上了正轨。我的意思是，我记得我刚拍完那部戏时，他们跟我谈的所有事情
after that was doing my goofy voice and being very, you know, the same Billy Madison again. And then I had that happy Gilmore thing that me and Hurley, he wrote. And they were trying to talk me out of that. They were saying, there was a movie called Ed with the monkey, you know, no, no, no, that's Ed TV. They said one with Matt LeBlanc and they want to be with the monkey and they were like, do that. That's more like Billy Madison.
在那之后，都是让我用那种傻乎乎的声音，再次扮演那个一模一样的比利·麦迪逊。然后我有了那个我和赫利写的《快乐吉尔莫》的点子。他们试图劝我放弃。他们说，有一部叫《艾德》的电影，讲的是猴子的故事，你知道的，不，不，不，那是《艾德电视》。他们说的是马特·勒布朗演的那部，他们想让我演那部有猴子的，他们说，拍那个吧。那个更像《阿呆闯学府》。
I said, I think, let me do, I'll do that one after I do the golf one. Is that okay? And they were like, no. And so that had to make a stand and say, no, no, no, we got to do this happy Gilmore movie. And By the way, two of the funniest movies ever, no kidding, a hugely successful. Thanks. I mean, I'm psyched that that's in my they go down in history as with all the other great
我说，我想，让我拍完高尔夫那部再拍那个吧。可以吗？他们说，不行。所以我必须坚持立场，说，不，不，不，我们得拍这部《快乐吉尔莫》。顺便说一句，这是有史以来最搞笑的两部电影，不开玩笑，非常成功。谢谢。我的意思是，我很高兴它能被列入我的……它们作为所有其他伟大的
comedy movies. I mean, thanks. Kind of cool. But then the success was so one after the other after the other, it was there was was there a strategic consideration when punch drunk love came about was or was that more of a react? Did did Paul Thomas Anderson come to you and only in hindsight, do you see it as a great strategic sort of balancing thing offsetting the goofiness or did you think ahead and kind
喜剧电影被载入史册。我的意思是，谢谢。挺酷的。但随后的成功是一部接一部，当《私恋失调》出现时，是否有过战略上的考虑，还是说这更多是一种反应？是保罗·托马斯·安德森主动找你的，还是你事后才觉得这是一种很好的战略平衡，抵消了那些傻气？还是你未雨绸缪，
of seek out something that might counterbalance all that? That was all luck. I mean, I in my head at will you, you did Strasburg, right? So I thought I was good at acting. I was like, wow, I'm going to surprise somebody someday and really act. But it wasn't on on my mind. I kind of liked Eddie Murphy. And I wanted that kind of career and I just wanted to be a comedian.
主动寻求某种能平衡这一切的东西？那纯粹是运气。我的意思是，在我脑子里，你会，你上过斯特拉斯堡表演学校，对吧？所以我以为我很会演戏。我当时想，哇，总有一天我会给某人一个惊喜，真正地演一次戏。但这并不在我的考虑范围内。我挺喜欢艾迪·墨菲的。我想要那样的职业生涯，我只想做一个喜剧演员。
And then I was doing, I think a little Nicky or something like that or yeah, something like that. And Paul was friends with Tom Cruise. They did Magnolia together. And I met Tom Cruise when Nicole Kim and hosted SNL. You know how you get to meet everybody because SNL. So I met Cruz and I'm like, God, Cruz had a Yankee hat on like dipped down low and he looked up and he goes, Hey, man, I was like in love with him, like, Oh my God, I'm in love with
然后我当时正在拍，我想是《魔鬼接班人》之类的，或者，是的，类似的东西。保罗和汤姆·克鲁斯是朋友。他们一起拍了《木兰花》。当妮可·基德曼主持《周六夜现场》时，我见到了汤姆·克鲁斯。你知道因为《周六夜现场》，你总能见到所有人。所以我见到了克鲁斯，我心想，天哪，克鲁斯戴着一顶洋基队的帽子，压得很低，他抬头看着我，说，嘿，伙计，我当时就像爱上了他一样，天哪，我爱上了
Tom Cruise. That makes jealous. Of course. Anyways, Tom called me up. I'm on my set. He goes, Hey, my friend, I'm doing a movie with my friend Paul. He's a great director and he's interested in doing a movie with you. Can I put him on the phone?
汤姆·克鲁斯。这让人嫉妒。当然。总之，汤姆给我打了电话。我当时在片场。他说，嘿，伙计，我正在和我朋友保罗拍一部电影。他是个很棒的导演，他对和你拍电影很感兴趣。我能让他接电话吗？
And I said, Yeah, yeah, sure, man. And he gets on and Paul was very nice and he was going, Hey, I loved Billy Madison. And I go, Okay, man, thanks. I didn't know who he was. And he's like, And I just love your movies and your albums. And I was like, Okay, cool, man. Okay, creep. Yeah.
我说，可以，可以，当然，伙计。他接了电话，保罗非常客气，他说，嘿，我喜欢《阿呆闯学府》。我说，好的，伙计，谢谢。我当时不知道他是谁。他说，我就是喜欢你的电影和你的专辑。我当时想，好的，酷，伙计。好的，怪胎。没错。
I didn't know what he was talking about. He's like, he goes, Is it okay if I write you a movie? I said, You can do whatever you want, man. That's great. Just stay away from my house. But he was, he was sweet. Yeah, I can tell you it was funny, but that's like Picasso saying, Is it okay if I paint you a painting?
我不知道他在说什么。他说，我可以为你写一部电影吗？我说，你想做什么都行，伙计。那太棒了。只要离我家远点就行。但他很贴心。是的，我可以告诉你这很有趣，但这就像毕加索说，我可以为你画一幅画吗？
I know, right? I know it was the luckiest thing. And then, and honest to God, fellas, I was, it was like 11 o'clock in the morning and I had nothing to do and Magnolia just came out and I said, I think that's that kid's movie. Wow. Paul, I'm going to go see that. And I went alone and I was in the front row was sold out with all of real film kind of
我知道，对吧？我知道这是最幸运的事情。然后，说实话，伙计们，当时大概是早上11点，我没什么事做，《木兰花》刚上映，我说，我想那是那个小子的电影。哇。保罗，我要去看看。我一个人去了，坐在前排，座无虚席，全是真正的电影
people. And I was looking up at it and I was going, I was fucking terrified. I was like, Oh, this guy's fucking better than me, man. I don't want to be in this. I'm going to ruin his movie, whatever the fuck, you know, I was like, Holy shit. And I called him up and on the way home, I, and I was like, Holy shit, I just saw your movies. Like, yeah, yeah.
圈内人。我抬头看着银幕，我当时吓坏了。我心想，哦，这家伙比我强多了，伙计。我不想演这个。我会毁了他的电影，不管怎样，你知道的，我当时想，天哪。我在回家的路上给他打了电话，我说，天哪，我刚看了你的电影。他说，是啊，是啊。
I was like, fucking the frogs in the holy shit. I was so excited about everybody. And I was like, Oh, fuck, man. So you're writing that movie, man. He goes, yeah, yeah, I'm almost done. I'm going to get it over to you. I was like, well, when the fuck is that coming? I started to get very excited.
我说，该死的，那些青蛙，天哪。我为每个人感到兴奋。我说，哦，该死，伙计。所以你在写那部电影，伙计。他说，是啊，是啊，我快写完了。我马上给你送过去。我说，那到底什么时候出来？我开始变得非常兴奋。
And then he did it so cool, man. I lived in this, this, I rented a house on the top of Bel Air Road with my buddies and he came up and he knocked on the door and he's like, I got the script and I said, here's my present to you. And I go, Oh, okay. He goes, go ahead and read it and tell me what you think. I go, you going to stay here? He goes, no, I'm going to go for a drive or something like that.
然后他做到了，太酷了，伙计。我当时租了贝莱尔路顶端的一栋房子，和我哥们住在一起，他走上来敲门，他说，我拿到剧本了，我说，这是我给你的礼物。我说，哦，好的。他说，去读读看，告诉我你的想法。我说，你要留在这儿吗？他说，不，我要去兜兜风什么的。
And I just sat in the other room and I read it and I was like, Oh my God, man, I don't know if I can fucking do this. It's no way. So he comes back after his drive and you, what you got a bunch of notes, right? Right. Couple things called. So marked up, it's a move this way. That's true.
我就坐在另一个房间里读它，我当时想，天哪，伙计，我不知道我能不能演这个。根本不可能。所以他兜风回来后，你，你有一堆笔记，对吧？没错。改了几处。所以改动很大，这得往这边移。是真的。
I was fucking scared like, like, yeah, you know, when you get something and you just go, Oh, geez, man, I always said I can do this ship and this is too much, man. And he talked me through and got me comfortable. He's incredible though. I mean, he's, yeah, his taste is just unreal. I mean, I loved that he's a huge comedy nerd too, apparently, and that he can see the amount of acting it takes for you to pull off believably what you do is, you know, right in line with his, with his taste and his abilities.
我当时吓坏了，就像，是的，你知道，当你拿到某样东西时，你只会说，哦，天哪，伙计，我一直说我能演这个，但这太难了，伙计。他开导我，让我感到自在。不过他太不可思议了。我的意思是，是的，他的品味简直不可思议。我的意思是，我喜欢他也是个超级喜剧迷，显然，他能看出你为了演好你所做的事情需要付出多少演技，你知道，这完全符合他的品味和能力。
And I just, I'm such a big fan of his and then the safty brothers, um, you know, I mean, uncut gems is just absolutely stunning. I don't mean to jump ahead, but they had fun at talking Betty and you talking at Aniston's was a great night. Oh, I just, I'm crazy about those guys as well. And I love the two of my favorite filmmakers. Well, that would be three, um, I put you as a lead in their films and I hope that you take as much pride in that as you deserve.
我只是他的超级粉丝，还有萨弗迪兄弟，嗯，我的意思是，《原钻》简直太震撼了。我不是想跳过话题，但他们在谈论贝蒂时玩得很开心，你在安妮斯顿家谈话的那晚很棒。哦，我简直也为那些家伙着迷。我爱这两个我最喜欢的电影制作人。好吧，那是三个，我把你作为他们电影的主演，我希望你为此感到自豪，这是你应得的。
Absolutely. I mean, it was a wonderful performance, man. It really was. It was, it was, uh, it was so nuanced and deep and this guy, like it was, you guys, you know, honestly, you could do it. You guys could do it too. I know you're all great. All three of you guys are great actors and funny as shit.
绝对的。我的意思是，那是一次精彩的表演，伙计。真的。那是，那是，嗯，那是如此细腻和深刻，这家伙，就像，伙计们，你知道，老实说，你能做到。你们也能做到。我知道你们都很棒。你们三个人都是很棒的演员，而且搞笑得要命。
And who's better? Yeah. Is there one that's better? You're number one. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. We're fighting for the silver over here.
谁更好？是的。有一个更好的吗？你是第一名。是的。好的。我们在这儿争夺银牌呢。
Yeah. You don't need to. You're both solid. But for Sean's number one. So the, I would imagine that you, um, you, you love the, uh, the, the creative process of doing a drama, um, and also the process of doing a comedy. I'm not going to ask you which is your favorite, but what would be your ideal ratio between comedy and drama and like, kind of like fun films with your friends versus kind of working
是的。你不需要。你们都很稳。但肖恩是第一名。所以，我想象你，嗯，你，你热爱拍剧情片的创作过程，也热爱拍喜剧的过程。我不会问你哪个是你的最爱，但你理想的喜剧和剧情片比例是多少？比如，和朋友拍有趣的电影，对比那种为导演工作？
for a director? I'm starting to get a lot of, uh, serious kind of offers and, and, and I love reading that stuff and I, but it is more of a decision in my brain. I'm like, shit. Once I say yes to that, then it's fucking, it's a whole other thing in your trailer and you're fucking rocked and you got to think into shit that makes you uncomfortable and right. It's slightly humiliating out there in front of people doing some of the shit they want
我开始收到很多，嗯，严肃类型的邀约，而且，而且，我喜欢读那些东西，但我脑子里确实要做个决定。我心想，该死。一旦我答应了，那就，那完全是另一回事了，在你的拖车里，你被折磨得够呛，你得去思考那些让你不舒服的事情，对吧。在人们面前做他们想让你做的一些事情，稍微有点丢人。
you to do. And, and, uh, and so it's a decision, but I like it. I want, I want to do that stuff. I also love doing the comedies shit and the fact that, you know, I just did it, the probably the goofiest movie I've done in a long time that, you know, shit I would have done when I was 23 and, but I still, I'm still happy doing Hubee, Hubee Halloween. Yeah. Yeah.
所以，这是一个决定，但我喜欢。我想，我想做那些事。我也喜欢拍喜剧，事实上，你知道，我刚拍完，可能是我很久以来拍过的最傻的电影，你知道，我23岁时会做的那种烂事，但是，我拍《万圣节的胡比》还是很开心。是的。是的。
Yeah. What is it? What is that? I don't know anything about it on Netflix, right? It's coming out on Netflix, uh, and it's a Halloween movie and it's all comedians and all it's like, uh, and our kids will love it. Yeah. Yeah.
是的。那是什么？那是什么？我对此一无所知，在Netflix上，对吧？它要在Netflix上上映了，嗯，这是一部万圣节电影，全是喜剧演员，而且它就像，嗯，我们的孩子会喜欢的。是的。是的。
It's, I do that because I get excited for kids to laugh and stuff like that and shit I've been doing my whole career and I still love that stuff. But being able to do both, I mean, good God that you can make, you know, an eight year old laugh and you can make, you know, a 70 year old cry. I mean, it's like, come on, like not a lot of people can do that. That's right. At all. Thank you.
我拍那个是因为我为孩子们能笑出来感到兴奋，诸如此类的事情，我整个职业生涯都在做这些，我仍然热爱那些东西。但能够两者兼顾，我的意思是，天哪，你能让一个八岁的孩子笑，也能让一个70岁的老人哭。我的意思是，这就像，拜托，没几个人能做到。没错。一点也没错。谢谢。
I'm lucky. Yeah. Yeah. Adam, you said, I read somewhere a long time ago, you said, I'll do this for as long as they let me. Yeah. And they, I love that. And they keep letting you because you're incredible and talented and likable and winning.
我很幸运。是的。是的。亚当，你说，我很久以前在某处读到过，你说，只要他们让我拍，我就一直拍下去。是的。而且他们，我喜欢那个。他们一直让你拍，因为你不可思议，有才华，讨人喜欢，而且成功。
And is there a time when you actually tell them that you're done or you're still having the time of your life? Like what, what else? Cause you work more than anybody. Like you never stop working. I, I, I, I, I don't know when, when I'm going to stop. I look at like, uh, you know, no Dustin and I know Nicholson and Pacino and those guys and those guys, they, they're addicted to work too.
有没有什么时候你真的告诉他们你不想拍了，还是你仍然在享受你的人生？比如，还有什么？因为你比任何人都努力工作。你从不停止工作。我，我，我，我，我不知道我什么时候会停下来。我看着，比如，嗯，你知道，达斯汀，我知道尼科尔森和帕西诺那些家伙，那些家伙，他们也对工作上瘾。
I mean, I had lunch with Pacino and he still gets excited about shit and he's just, I read this amazing script and he still wants to kick ass and, and, uh, I, I, I kind of think I could stop. And then I, I, when I'm stopped like this pandemic, man, would, would not work and holy shit was I lose in my mind and fucking every day becomes the same jumpy shit and my fucking family certainly wanted me to work. They were like, Jesus Christ, he's fucking insane. Get him out of here.
我的意思是，我和帕西诺吃过午饭，他仍然对事情感到兴奋，他只是，我读了这个很棒的剧本，他仍然想大干一场，而且，嗯，我，我，我有点觉得我可以停下来。然后我，当我停下来的时候，就像这次疫情，伙计，没法工作，天哪，我简直要疯了，每天都变成同样无聊的烂事，我的家人当然希望我工作。他们就像，天哪，他疯了。让他出去吧。
I heard you were out on the golf course a little bit. Yeah. We heard, we heard from a friend that. Oh, I hid it to your buddy. Yeah. Who's your buddy that I almost hit by the way? Tom Warner. Tell Tommy I'm sorry.
我听说你在高尔夫球场待了一会儿。是的。我们听说，我们从一个朋友那里听说。哦，我差点打到你哥们。是的。顺便问一下，我差点打到谁？汤姆·华纳。告诉汤米我很抱歉。
Okay. Are you a big golfer? Cause I'm finding that that is, uh, keeping me off the streets a little bit during this pandemic. You've been playing a lot. Yeah. Well, you know, I, I, I met you long time ago, like 20 years ago and you, you were friends with Brill.
好的。你是高尔夫球高手吗？因为我发现这，嗯，在这场疫情期间让我远离街头。你最近打得很多吗？是的。好吧，你知道，我，我，我很久以前见过你，大概20年前，你是布里尔的朋友。
Yeah. I think back then, and I was at a party and I saw some thing that, uh, they interviewed you on like a show and you had a, uh, you golfed on it and I saw you at the thing. I said, dude, I just saw you did. You got a great swing and you kind of like, okay. Okay. And that was it. But I remember going, Oh, that fucking guy knows how to golf.
是的。我想那时，我在一个派对上，我看到了一些东西，嗯，他们在某个节目上采访你，你在上面打了高尔夫，我在那个东西上看到了你。我说，伙计，我刚看到你做了。你的挥杆很棒，你有点像，好的。好的。就是这样。但我记得我当时想，哦，那个该死的家伙知道怎么打高尔夫。
He's got a great swing. He does have a great swing. I didn't have a career at that point. He's got, he's got a great swing. And we, we both taken it up in the last couple of weeks, we've been a little irritating to our significant others. Yeah. It's a long day golf day, right?
他的挥杆很棒。他的挥杆确实很棒。那时我还没有职业生涯。他有，他有很棒的挥杆。我们，我们俩在过去几周都开始打了，我们对我们的另一半来说有点烦人。是的，那是漫长的一天，高尔夫日，对吧？
Are you addicted to it? Or is it just something that you just kind of slap around? No. Tell your buddy what happened was I'm a member of Riviera and I fucking live right, right down the street. So, so I, um, I haven't golfed since I've had kids. I don't golf that much, just like you're saying, well, hey, because of the whole five hours away and the, the, the stare you get when you get home of like, are you fucking kidding
你对它上瘾了吗？还是只是随便打打？不。告诉你的哥们发生了什么，我是里维埃拉的会员，我他妈就住在街下。所以，所以，我，嗯，我有孩子后就没打过高尔夫了。我没打那么多，就像你说的，好吧，嘿，因为整个五小时的时间，还有你回家时得到的那个眼神，就像，你在开什么玩笑
me? While they're in school, we got a pass while they're in school, right? That's right. That's supposed to be it. But I get, I still get nervous leaving the house and coming back to a fucking a whole other mood. So I know what you guys are talking about because when I make banana bread, I'm like, do I, do I pull it out at the right, like when is the, do I leave it in five, another
吗？当他们在上学时，我们有通行证，当他们在上学时，对吧？没错。应该是这样。但我离开家再回到那种该死的完全不同的情绪中，我仍然会感到紧张。所以我知道你们在说什么，因为当我做香蕉面包时，我心想，我，我把它拿出来的时间对吗，比如什么时候，我把它再留
five minutes? Do I not? It's crazy. Just like it. I just feel guilty about paying all those dues over their Riviera and not using the course. So Will and I want to help you out. Yeah.
五分钟？我不留？这太疯狂了。就像那样。我只是觉得在里维埃拉付了那么多会费却不使用球场感到内疚。所以威尔和我想帮你一把。是的。
We're just kind of getting a little bit more active out there. So you just let us know. You guys are playing real well though, like in the 80s or 70s. No, he is, I'm playing like shit, but Jason's game is getting together. But what we've been doing is we've been calling guys that we know who we know belong places because we don't. And we go, that's where you come in. Hey, you playing these days and then they go, yeah, and we go, well, Jason, we're available
我们只是在那儿变得更活跃了一点。所以你只要告诉我们就行。不过你们打得真好，比如在80杆或70杆左右。不，他打得好，我打得像屎一样，但杰森的球技正在进步。但我们一直在做的是，我们一直在给那些我们知道属于某些地方的家伙打电话，因为我们不属于那里。我们说，这就是你发挥作用的地方。嘿，你最近在打球吗？然后他们说，是的，我们说，好吧，杰森，我们周三有空。我们愿意陪你。是的。哇，伙计。亚当，我总是，特别是像，我总是问有趣的父母这个，比如威尔和杰森是我认识的最有趣的人。他们总是让我笑得那么厉害。我们一直在讨论，他们的孩子觉得他们有趣吗？
on Wednesday. We're willing to keep you company. Yeah. Wow, man. Adam, I'm always especially like, I always ask funny parents this, like Will and Jason are two of the funniest people I know. They always make me laugh so hard. And we've always talked about, do their kids find them funny?
你的孩子觉得你有趣吗？而且你显然他妈的太搞笑了。你的孩子觉得你有趣吗，还是根本不觉得？或者，比如，他们懂你的喜剧感吗？他们看你的搞笑电影吗？是的。是的。是的。我的意思是，我在家里表现还不错。
Do your kids find, and you're obviously fucking hilarious. Your kids find you funny or not at all? Or like, do they get your sense of comedy? Do they watch your funny movies? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I'm pretty good at home.
我让他们笑，因为当我要求他们练习什么东西或者那种家伙时，他们就像，他们不喜欢他，但他们喜欢搞笑的我。他们懂，我做得还不错。哦，好。我让他们感到自在。然后我肯定经常尝试变得有趣，并试图逗笑。我并不总是，总是得分。就像我试图让他们从他们的情绪中走出来。
I make them laugh because when I'm asking them to practice something or that kind of guy, they're like, they don't like him, but they like the funny me. They get, they, I do pretty good. Oh, good. I make them comfortable. And then I definitely try to be funny a lot and try to get laughs. I don't always, always score. Like I try to take them out of their moves.
我想成长过程中，那也是我的招数。当我感觉到我父亲快要对我发疯时，当然，我讲了几个笑话来缓和气氛。我的意思是，孩子们也是，当我看到他们因为某事心烦意乱时，我就讲笑话。你们也这样做吗？100%。亚当，那谁是管教者？如果你，如果你让他们笑，每个人都想，我的意思是，是杰基在
I think growing up that, that was my move too. When I felt my father about to fucking go nuts on me, of course, I said a few jokes to lighten them up. I mean, the kids too, when I see them upset about something, I go to the jokes. Do you guys do that? 100%. Adam, who's the disciplinarian then? If you, if you make them laugh, everyone wants to, I mean, is Jackie the one that's
制定法律，还是你们俩都做？我听说你们在谈论这个。你比阿曼达轻松，对吧？我比较轻松，但，我想象你可能和我相似，你是班级小丑，你是那个爱开玩笑的人，但如果你需要的话，你可以一直摇摆到另一边，变得非常严肃，中间真的什么都没有。哦，是的。
laying down the law or do you do both? I heard you guys talking about this. You're lighter than Amanda, right? I'm lighter, but it's, I would imagine you might be similar to me where you're super, you're, you're the, you're the class clown, you're the joker, but then you can swing all the way to the other side and really get serious if you need to and there's really nothing in between. Oh yeah.
我想我变得非常疯狂，当我只是被吓到时，当我像，不，你必须知道这个，因为就在我开始提高嗓门时，杰基不会那样做，就像阿曼达不会那样做。她覆盖了整个中间地带，而我就像书挡。杰基也在中间切断了我的话，开始说。她从你手中拿走了武器，对吧？你说对了。是的。
I think I get really fucking nuts when I just scared eyes at me when I'm like, no, you have to know this because right when I start raising my voice that Jackie would not do like Amanda would not do that. She covers the whole middle ground and I'm like the bookends. Jackie cuts me off in the middle of that too and starts going. She takes a weapon out of your hand, right? You got it. Yeah.
她说，他们听不懂。不，武器，我想，是我他妈的大声，对吧？你知道，突然间半愤怒的语气，她只是说，停下，停下，你不能，他们不明白你在做什么。他们只是像，他们必须知道这个，好吧，听听我有多大声。是的。没错。然后它就消失了，然后我大部分时间都是个马屁精。
She's like, they can't understand. No, the weapon, I guess, is my fucking loud, right? You know, semi angry tone all of a sudden, she's just like, stop, stop, you can't, they don't understand what you're doing. They're just like, they have to know this, all right, listen to how loud I am. Yeah. Exactly. And then it goes away and then I'm a kiss ass most of the time.
我喜欢让他们他妈的开心。我，我喜欢他们开心和欢笑，但我给他们施加了一些压力。不是关于，我不知道你们是否有这个，但我做的一切，我只会去外面练习，他妈的篮球，棒球，甚至骑自行车，我只会像在自己他妈的世界里，只是绕圈开车，试图跳下路缘，试图翘起车头，不管那他妈的是什么。而且我没看到我的孩子像我一样想做那个。所以我心想，没什么你想擅长的吗？
I like keeping them fucking happy. I, I like when they're happy and laughing and, but I put some pressure on them. Not about, I don't know if you guys have this, but everything I did, I would just go outside and practice and fucking basketball, baseball, even bike riding, I would just like be in my own fucking world, just driving in circles, trying to hop off a curb, trying to pop a wheelie, whatever the fuck that was. And I don't see my kids want to do that as much as me. So I'm like, there's nothing you want to get good at.
没错。我做那个，那个烂事。而他们只是像，不，只是不是你想让我们擅长的。我们想擅长我们喜欢的，你知道。好吧。好吧，在结束时，我有一个最后一个问题问你。是什么让你在所有这些，所有这些生活领域中最快乐？看起来好像有很多和谐，一切都在顺利进行，而且有这么多事情
Right. I do that, that shit. And they're just like, not, just not what you want us to get good at. We want to get good at what we like, you know. All right. Well, in closure, I have one last question for you. What makes you happiest in all of these, all of these areas of your life, there's, it seems like there's so much harmony and everything's kind of cruising and there's so many things
带给你快乐。我敢打赌你会说家庭或类似之类的垃圾。顺便说一句，这是杰森在看，这会很有启发性。他在寻找让他快乐的东西。所以他在寻找线索，无论你能找到什么样的线索，在，是的。如果你必须，通常你在哪里发现自己最，那种只是宁静，这是美好的一天？好吧，该死，我不得不说当家里一切顺利时，一切都很好。
to bring you happiness. I'll bet you'll say family or some garbage like that. And by the way, this is Jason's looking at, this is going to be informative. He's looking for something to make him happy. So he's looking for clues, whatever kind of clue you can find in, yeah. If you had to, usually where do you find yourself the most sort of just serene and this is a great day? Well, fuck, I would have to say when shit's going good at home, everything is good.
那是真的。你知道我的意思吗？当孩子和你的妻子或伴侣快乐时，没有什么可担心的，你只是他妈的自由地做回你小时候的样子，你知道，那就是我觉得，该死，我在拍电影。这太棒了。当我他妈的在拍电影时，我接到家里的电话，有些事情不对劲，我就像，我他妈的迷失了，直到那件事得到解决，对吧？
That's true. You know what I mean? When the kids and your wife or your partner are happy and there's nothing else to be concerned about, you're just fucking free to be who you were as a kid, you know, like that's when I feel like, shit, I'm making a movie. This is great. When I'm fucking making a movie and I get a call from home and something's off, I'm like, I'm fucking lost until that shit gets resolved, right?
而且你必须演得好，其他演员在开玩笑，而你有点像，什么？就像你落后了一拍。而且你在看手机，因为你心想，该死，这事能解决吗？是的。是的。是的。
And you got to act good and the other actors are joking around and you're kind of like, what? Like you're beat behind. And you're looking at your phone because you're like, fuck is this thing going to resolve itself? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
是的。你他妈的心碎，无缘无故的心碎。然后突然间我加倍了我的，因为我现在有一个像前妻一样的人，所以我想要确保艾米是快乐的，还有我的伴侣，每个人，我有太多我担心他们是否快乐的人了。当然。当然。是的。
Yeah. You're fucking heart, heartache, heartache for no reason. And then all of a sudden I doubled mine because I now have like an ex-wife so I want to make sure that Amy's happy and also my partner and every, I've got like way too many people I'm worried about are happy now. Sure. Sure. Yeah.
所以这听起来像个抱怨。听着，我是个非常幸运的家伙，但仍然。是的，绝对。不，我们都是，但深度绝对有起有落，在我自己的脑子里。我不能，我从来没有他妈的24小时快乐的一天。我没看到那会发生，但我有我，我工作的时候，我相当，好吧，你们呢，当你们工作时？你们像，这太棒了？
So it sounds like a complaint. Listen, I'm a very lucky guy, but still. Yes, absolutely. No, we all are, but the depth definitely ups and downs in my own brain. I can't, I never have a fucking 24 hour happy day. I don't see that ever, ever coming my way, but I have what I'm, what I'm working, I'm pretty like, all right, let's, how about you guys when you're working? Are you like, this is great?
还是你们有点像？是的。你就像，你不在状态，因为你在工作，你在片场，你在那个东西里。当你真正投入其中时，那是一个很棒的空间。我记得对我来说，我最快乐的时光之一是，当杰森和我刚开始拍《发展受阻》时，所以人们，那时你发短信没那么多，因为每个人仍然必须用翻盖手机。
Or are you kind of like? Yeah. You're like, you're off because you're working and it's in your onset and you're in that thing. That is a great space when you're really in it. I remember for me, one of my happiest times was when, when Jason and I were first doing a rest of development and so people, you didn't text as much back then it was because everybody still had to flip phones.
我记得我们得到了一个新的翻盖手机，太兴奋了，还有一个双向寻呼机。我们有那些，我们有那些，我只是记得就像，你会去，你会去工作，离开你的拖车，不管你是在哪里化妆，你去片场，你在那儿待了四个小时，你没有联系外面的世界，你在做这个工作，你在其中。那对我来说是一个快乐的记忆。但如果你知道，家里有点不对劲，你仍然不能百分之百享受它。
I remember we got a new flip phone that was so psyched and a two way pager thing. We had those, and we had those, and I just remember like, you'd go to, you'd go to work, you leave your trailer, whatever you're dressing, you go on a set and you're on there for like four hours and you're not contacting the outside world and you're in this thing working and you're in it. That is a happy memory for me. But if you know that there's, that there's something a little sideways back home, you still can't a hundred percent enjoy it.
所以在家保持领先一点，确保一切运行顺利，明天也会很顺利，因为我不仅仅是，你知道，你知道，我正在做一些积极的事情来保持它向前发展并保持领先。我最近一直在尝试这样做。是的。我妻子，当我我知道我周二有，我有一个相当，那个大场景，等等等等。她会说，哦，好的。
So staying a little bit ahead at home and making sure that that's all running smoothly and it will be smooth again tomorrow too, because I'm not just, you know, you know, I'm doing something proactive to keep it going forward and staying ahead of it. I've been trying to do lately. Yeah. My wife's, when I know I go on Tuesday, I got a pretty, that big scene, blah, blah, blah. She'll go, oh, okay.
然后她会有点阻止烂事。她不应该在大日子里给我提烂事。哦，那很好。那挺好的。然后。是的，那很好。总之。然后。
And then she'll kind of block shit. She should not bring shit up to me on a big day. Oh, that's nice. That's pretty nice. And then. Yeah, that's nice. Anyways. And then.
是的。你和她对台词吗？一直。而且她，她很擅长发现我没打算在场景中做的事情，然后说，嗯，你不知道那句台词是什么意思吗？哦，那太棒了。她为我做那个。是的。
Yeah. Do you run lines with her? All the time. And she, she's good at finding shit that I wasn't going to do in the scene and going like, well, don't you know what that line means? Oh, that's awesome. She does that for me. Yeah.
是的。是的。我一直在这里做。你和斯科蒂做那个吗？不断地。那很好。你擅长背台词吗，亚当？不太擅长。
Yeah. Yeah. I do it all the time here. You do that with Scotty? Constantly. That's nice. Are you good at memorizing your lines, Adam? Not too good.
你呢？杰森是业内最好的。史上最好的。嗯，它真的很擅长。那是那个他妈的电视烂事。那是那个电视烂事。是的。他妈的不可思议。
How about you? Jason's the best in the biz. The best of all time. Well, it's really good at it too. That's that fucking TV shit. That's that TV shit. Yeah. Fucking unbelievable.
我很惊讶《周六夜现场》没有那种磨练你。还是你一直看着卡片？两者都有。他们告诉你去，对吧？我会做那种恐慌的事情，就像在莱特曼之前。我记得我在《周末更新》上做了这个烂事，我穿了服装，疯狂的，我是疯狂的泡菜手臂和所有这些烂事，我必须做这个事情，我是疯狂的桌下家伙。
I'm surprised that Saturday Night Live didn't kind of grind that in on you. Or were you just looking at the cards the whole time? Both. They tell you to, right? I would do the panic thing like before Letterman. I remember I did this shit on Weekend Update where I did costumes, crazy, I'm crazy pickle arm and all this shit and I had to do this thing where I was, I'm crazy under the desk guy.
所以我记得在我的脑子里，我去了，当你是一个疯狂的桌下家伙时，没有提示卡，因为你要去桌子下面，你必须记住你的烂事。我记得我他妈的现场直播。我去了我的桌子下面，就像，我的头在想，天哪，没有他妈的提示卡。你有麻烦了，伙计。我想我记住了大部分并完成了它。但不，我喜欢知道提示卡在周围。你和沃利很熟，对吧？
So I remember in my head, I went, when you're crazy under the desk guy, there's no cue cards because you're going under the desk and you got to remember your shit. And I remember I fucking live. I went under my desk and it was like, my head's going, holy shit, there's no fucking cue cards. You're in trouble, man. And I think I remembered most of them and got it done. But no, I like knowing the cue cards were around. You were tight with Wally, right?
沃利那时在做提示卡吗？哦，是的。当然。我认识沃利。他前几天突然给我发短信。他真是个好人。哦，是的。他做得很好。
Was Wally doing cue cards back then? Oh yeah. Of course. I know Wally. He just texted me out of the blue the other day. He's such a good guy. Oh yeah. He's doing well.
我刚得到他妈的他在做的其他生意。是的。我不知道。他，是的。沃利是那个家伙，提示卡家伙。他现在有一个游乐园。我想他刚开了一个游乐园。哦，是的。
I just got fucking some other business he's doing right now. Yeah. I don't know. He's, yeah. Wally was the guy, the cue card guy. He's got an amusement park now. I think he just started an amusement park. Oh yeah.
是的。是的。是的。哦，约翰·坎迪在那里工作。那很好。亚当，你非常慷慨地给了我们这么多时间。谢谢你首先答应参加这个节目。谢谢你们邀请我，伙计们。
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, John Candy's working there. It's nice. Adam, you're incredibly generous to give us all this time. Thank you for saying yes to doing the show in the first place. Thank you for asking me guys.
我们爱你。你能想象你的节目吗？这是一件很棒的事情，你们在做，而且能一直待在一起，你们是很棒的家伙。我们很幸运。我们非常感激。所以期待明天在高尔夫球场见到你。我们大概会在8:30，9:00到那里。
We love you. Can you imagine your show? It's a great thing you're doing and getting to hang out all the time together and you're great guys. We're pretty lucky. We're very appreciative. So looking forward to seeing you on the golf course tomorrow. We'll be there probably at 8.30, 9.00.
我们要去打电话。是的。我们要先热身。我们不喜欢热身，但我们会热身的。好的。没错，伙计。好的。我们爱你。
We're getting on the call. Yeah. We're going to warm up first. We don't like to warm up, but we will warm up. All right. Right on, man. All right. We love you.
向你的家人问好。也爱你。爱你，伙计。谢谢，哥们。回头见，伙计们。好的。再见，伙计。好的。
Say hi to your family. Love you too. Love you, pal. Thanks, buddy. See you guys. Okay. Bye, pal. All right.
回头见，伙计们。哦，他太棒了。真是个好人，正派的人。他太有吸引力了。就像我可以听他讲几个小时。顺便说一句，他谈论他所有的焦虑，我心想，是的，我完全理解。我有同感。
Later, guys. Oh, he's fantastic. What a good, decent guy. He's so engaging. Like I could listen to him talk for hours. And by the way, how he's talking about all that anxiety that he has, I'm like, yeah, I totally get that. I relate.
是的。他保持，他保持得如此人性化，当他有很多机会，可能不是这样时，他能够对他朋友保持非常忠诚。他也拿出了很棒的产品。他有他的家人陪着他。就像他一直很聪明，他把所有这些对他可用的碎片以某种方向组合在一起，我想象这会延续如此多的快乐给
Yeah. He stayed. He stayed so human when he's had many opportunities, probably not to, he's able to stay very loyal to his friends. He's also putting up a great product. He's got his family with him. Like he's just been so smart the way he's kind of put all these pieces that are available to him into a certain direction that I would imagine perpetuates so much happiness for
他，以及许多和他亲近的人，显然还有他的观众。他是一个好人。是的。是的。他是一个全面发展的家伙，他有一种快乐的生活。对我来说，无论如何，我喜欢看着那些过着快乐生活的人，因为这不取决于他们做什么，而是取决于许多其他事情，从家庭开始。
him and so many people that are close to him and obviously his audience as well. He's a good human being. Yeah. Yeah. He's a well-rounded guy and he's got a sort of happy life. And for me anyway, I like looking at the people who are having a happy life because it's not defined by what they do, but it's defined by so many other things, starting with family.
以及他们用生活中可用的东西做什么，无论是，你知道，非常昂贵，好的东西还是不，你用你拥有的东西做什么，我认为是一个很好的测试。谢谢亚当加入我们。那太棒了。太好了，杰森。我喜欢那个。天哪。
And what they do with the things that are available to them in their life, whether it be, you know, really expensive, nice things or not, what you do with what you've got, I think is a good test. Thank you to Adam for joining us. That was great. So good, Jason. I like that. Gosh.
他最好带我们去打高尔夫。他最好带我们去打高尔夫。谢谢你，听众，加入我们又一个小时的SmartLess。哦。再见。再见。Smart。Bless。
He better take us golfing. He better take us golfing. And thank you, listener, for joining us for another hour of SmartLess. Oh. Bye. Bye. Smart. Bless.
Smart。Bless。SmartLess。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。
Smart. Bless. SmartLess. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Smart. Bless. SmartLess. 本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。